this is a production of cornell
university
okay so one test we do to test for the
compaction of the soil is called
bulk density this measures the density
of the soil per a certain volume and
first what we're going to do is move
away the organic matter of the soil so
we're not going to be testing that
density we want to get down to the
actual soil
i think that's good i see roots so once
that's removed
we're going to take a known volume
which is this cylinder here and place it
on the
soil put a block to distribute the
weight
and we're going to basically push that
cylinder into the soil
we want to pound this in so the cylinder
is level with the soil
just a little bit more
okay basically we've got our cylinder in
the soil
and we want to get that known volume of
soil
out and put it in a bag which will then
dry and weigh
so i have my bag here which i'll label
always good to label you know
men's garden
and then getting this out sometimes
takes a little effort
you have to move around this cylinder
it's very dry so it's making it harder
we can lever this a little bit
we want to make sure all the soil is in
the cylinder
let me put this underneath
make sure we have a known volume
and then we allow that soil to
get out into the soil into the bag
because now we have a known volume in a
bag which will dry this
soil and the dry weight per volume
gives us the bulk density it's a measure
of compaction of the soil
it's very useful when you're doing soil
testing
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu